okay four people joining this livestream
this is yet another episode in trying to
finish off a database integration
functionality for version 12 of language
um okay so last time we had finished
going through if I'm not mistaken the UM
functions let's see I met database
connectivity is that not reviewed no
this has been reviewed right it was that
read there I think that was a bug that I
asked you to get fixed um when I tried
to do a 12 plus thing somebody should
just fix it I mean it's just a glitch in
the internal structure there okay so
this relational database function
sorry I think we don't have there the
new symbols about database connect and
database disconnect tilde I'm not sure
if we leave them
look it might be useful to have a line
that just lists them there um so what
are they now
so they're from here database Connect
database oh no their manual
disconnection we don't need those but
what about database reference
you
is that relevant here I think that is
relevant is it is it can you speak up
please okay anybody hear me
yes sure okay so do you think it's
relevant or not yeah here yes well well
is it sufficient to just say what will
people mostly use database reference or
not or will they mostly just use
relational database probably relational
database okay and let's not put that on
this page okay
okay this this page looks fine instead
of that page andraia consider that page
done okay I think the mostly ones that
we are missing also that you never have
looked at them are the first symbols
that like some foil aggregated extended
and combined okay now we started going
through this over these last time right
so Col I assume you made the updates
from last time right
kalo
yes I was confused if you said Carol or
karma was about to say that Sundra
I know it's under yeah iishe ort and the
I tried to make them a little less
verbose okay um okay okay so the
examples here
why are those the first few entities who
knows well where they ordered that way
it's a little confusing to say its first
view why don't we say containing n
entities from
you
and then say okay so now okay um is this
up to em or is this some
does that mean up to n yes it's up to n
you
okay I think
could it be something that is an
extended sort identity class do you
understand my question
Oh what do you mean by that okay yeah I
wrote it it's not guaranteed in that
case okay wait wait wait
do they know I might be wrong do you
remember if it adds an extra layer of
select if you're just adding an
annotation it depends on what what's the
type of the annotation I think because
if it's if it uses another annotation
then it might so we don't guarantee that
it so is not adding an extra layer of
select color it's the first n entities
from the internal representation of
class
this representation may change when
operations are done on class is that
correct that correct what kind of
operations I don't know I mean I'm
trying it you said this may not stay the
same so it's one way to say it yes ok so
then um sorted entity class can be used
to define a specific ordering for
entities
I think that's enough to say that
no but if you do if you delete the next
line then it's a little bit confusing I
think which next line the one you just
deleted because you have to somehow
connect it to say that the class inside
the sample then the class has to be
sorted entity class for that order to
persist you kind of say okay I
understand okay so
can be used to define an entity class
whether to be used to represent an
entity class with a specific ordering
I'm trying to avoid just saying you
apply man we conclude give examples down
below in which you give sampled entity
class of sort identity class but I'm
trying to avoid saying that that's the
naked form that you always have to use
because I don't think it is
naked form so
the class of sorted into class that can
be more complicated than that to care
what I'm saying for all other cases I
don't think we can guarantee the
ordering are you sure okay at least
within the context of relational
databases
well I don't know about other things so
I think this is sufficient basically
gives a hint that if you want something
with I mean we can give examples down
below why don't you then just write sort
identity class as class or something
like that to connect it to the class
argument of the sample energy class
because that's specifically not what I
was trying to say ok if you say ok look
you
you
you
are you happy with this yes all right I
mean it's not it's not
you
I shouldn't say something this is about
all we're gonna get here
that didn't work right
you
does it give class or is it equivalent
to class
do you understand what I'm asking
it's the letter it's equivalent to class
does not return
you
yeah the answer to bettin on the
livestream is this is not a random
sampling cuz random sampling is hard to
do so far as we know
future thing is to figure out how to do
and I'm so employed
oh boy do you didn't did you already do
the simplification here and this is the
result
yes this is a good one so possibly the
second usage message well you're going
forward well no we've reviewed sorted
entity classes that corrects it okay
except we got it wrong because it
doesn't refer to any of the other entity
class functions come on guys
although I mean we're in the was yes and
the sales to all six of the others now I
don't think so I think it should refer
to the ones that are relevant
you
but then maybe just density class
because it's the only one that you can
do filtering with well what about
sampled entity cause I think that's
relevant here
you
okay
so we did review filter identity cloths
yeah I think so
I think when we sing it extended okay
all right let's go
okay all right okay so I go get it it's
complicated so let's do extend it first
okay
okay what does entity funk take
what does it what do you apply auntie I
mean Ltd funk is applied that it's not
applied 20 hing right now but it's going
to be applied to each entity in class no
no it's going to be applied to the
entity to the landing class okay in
order to give that value of that
function
yes derived from class
but with
but it's derived see does the class okay
represents an entity class I would like
to use the word extended since it's in
the name of the function
um instead of say edn you you can say
extent by the you know that's even more
obscure I think um
also I think what's really missing here
is to make clear that F has always to be
an entity function not just an arbitrary
function we come up with
okay okay okay fair enough is that true
even in the case of in-memory entity
stores so we don't want to make a
distinction between the ones so I
understand it but I'm asking you does it
work if you have a non entity function
function therefore in our why not
why not make it work so we could make it
work after some consideration maybe but
what happens if you start with an
in-memory stores start developing your
program switch to another back-end and
it stops working so the idea is that
independent of the back end the
functionality works the same but that's
lowest-common-denominator I mean if you
have some back-end some brain-dead you
know database back-end that doesn't
support I don't know dates or something
does that mean you can't use dates
that argument is not gonna work to say
it's always lowest common denominator
because the lowest common denominator I
said is that no but it's it's different
student because four days example you
gave we basically give a contract that
we implement the missing peach features
so it's not like we always pick the ones
that are the lowest common denominator
we also step up to it when necessary but
it's a part of a core language so if you
start blurring this distinction all
right okay okay
for now I'll agree with you I'm not
convinced for the future but I'll agree
with you for now okay so okay represents
an entity class see what's confusing to
me is that the entity class
that the idea that an entity class
contains a property
um
um represents derive but extended
you
by
having a new computer property
name is it does it have to be a string
they're the computer property nails yes
okay new computer property quotes name
obtained from each entity in the class
in class by applying the entity function
F do you believe in that that's not
medically not right because it's not a
property that is obtained by the
property value okay well if we go into
such detail we might as well I don't
know whether it's worth definitely not
in this place but at some point we need
to say that this application sometimes
happens on the backhand side sooo it's
not like yeah I understand represents an
entity class
derived from class i okay i'm getting
bikes but extended by adding
a new computer property name whose value
for each entity is obtained by applying
the entity function f
seem reasonable does a wise entity
function they're not linked in 2000
I hate saying that the entity function
function
and you just leave function out yeah
like that I hate doing that I don't like
using that as an adjective form I mean I
hate using our function names as
adjectives like that I don't really like
doing this for some reason I it's gotten
us and knock all kinds of trouble um
you
I'm gonna say this
you
oh I hate this
[Music]
you know what I'm just gonna say by
plugging the entity function f and then
we'll explain it okay so here this is
just f12
defined by the functions of Sabai
okay now let's explain what's going on
what is this
you
attended with
what okay so first of all in extended
and the class class named arrow F the
function f must be
and entity function object
okay did you see that that rule didn't
turn into a rule yeah I don't understand
that that seems seems wrong okay let's
look at this we've got a bunch of
interesting comments on the live stream
which we'll look at in just a second um
what is this
entity properties
is effectively with this appended yes I
agree
is that the okay
okay
can be used
you
can be used to
true
get values for
what what does it do if the thing has I
stand if the thing has that name what
does it do if the class already has that
name its shadows the previous one so I
think we gotta say it actually not
shadowing but instead though it does
equate the string form anymore so you
have to use the full form of each entity
property now wait a second
now it doesn't shuttle I mean the latest
one you should be able to still use
string right but there are the ones
which were there before you can get to
only by using the full one correct or
not what happened
look if I have a class that has you know
height and weight in it okay with those
names and then I say extended entity
class weight arrow something or other
how do I do something you write between
the weight that was already there in the
weight that I added using an entity
property with either just a type or the
complex type in the first argument
but how does that help me if that class
already had that thing called wait how
do I refer to the wait which I added
versus the wait will try nobodies thing
oh I see yeah the first argument will be
different okay all right all right but
my point has been that you can still use
the short thing this name just for the
most recently defined property and the
other ones that were there before will
be accessible by a longer first argument
entity property
that's what I wanted to say but it's
actually not true at least in the
current implementation no no as soon as
you're an ambiguity it does not choose
one for you
also you're saying as soon as it is
there is number duty you have to always
define entity property was a long one
yes
what if you don't and just use a string
it will give you an error yes oh okay I
didn't know that okay so listen listen
here's what we got to say here
[Music]
okay so
entity so so extended entity class
okay
I think what we want to say um I've got
an idea how to say this standard entity
class can be used whoops
well okay I'm at
okay what we could say entity value of
class comma quotes name can be used to
get
from an extended entity class so long as
oh gosh that's really confusing okay
hold on let's try this this can be used
even if class already has a property
with the specific width
whose name
his name great um
you
you
even if Klaus already has a property
whose name is quotes new
um
in this case
the full
the property
you
the new okay works adds a new computer
property in this case however the new
computer property must be referred to
new compute property must be referred to
by the full form
enter the property of entity class blah
blah blah like this right yes
oh let me ask something and the old ones
should also be referred referred since
this change powerful or no no no the old
one can be referred to by that by the by
it's um
this case however the new computer
property must be referred to by the form
using the full
okay now we can say if a new property if
the name of a new property does not
conflict with the names of any existing
properties then entity value of class
comma new can be used to
get
values of the new property right
yes okay and this
okay now this one here entity properties
let's see one thing we should say
I think we should say this first entity
property the
for an extended entity class
you
the name the full name of the new
property added is
this whole thing entered the property of
extended entity class or is that a
tautological statement
it's probably not it's good to refer to
just another time to tell it because it
might not be very obvious it's this
right
yes
okay then we don't need to say this
because that's pretty obvious
you
and we don't need to say that either
okay now here what on earth is with
doing there
well my proposal for that function would
have been this added property or
something like that so it's similar to
this and edit hold something that you
introduced temporarily except it does it
from inside out rather than from outside
in yes so that might be confusing in
that sense
you
and also it's not a scoping kostik
really well with us I mean I think that
the way to think about it is like we're
introducing a new constant only that the
semantics is different but in that sense
it's kind of the same thing yeah but are
at least two differences which are is
pretty important in which I just
mentioned camp can I am a look at what
the see also should be here by the way
um I don't understand with is that does
that survivor is that I don't understand
that at all
can I remove it by the way this should
surely refer to entity store which
certainly has computer properties in it
or am I totally confused
yes so four entities toast that's a
different mechanism to close properties
directly in the store okay and this
should probably refer to I don't know
whether it's combined or aggregated
entity class
probably aggregated alright let's take a
look at the comments on our livestream
here uh let's see um
okay wait a minute Seth is saying if you
write entity properties of extended
entity class you get an ugly output if
you wrap canonical name you get
something more attractive so what's the
issue there is the issue that we don't
have print forms for anything that it's
going to be fixed soon right Tony
now that we I mean external user haven't
seen it yet but with the design work
with it for single entities I'm sure it
should apply also to 20 property it's
complex it should you just gain an angle
so that right Tony
well we haven't explicitly discussed any
yet okay can I can I look at an example
wet West was a good example to look at
here just in general well just take the
first example in extend the NT class and
apply Eng property suits okay so this
okay that's okay now we say entity
properties
oh my gosh what's gonna happen here
what the heck is this Oh
but because
it's because country's a healthy
property yeah okay all right I okay
is there anything we can do about that
well I mean this isn't obviously
hopeless why is it hopeless it is not
obviously hopeless I mean it's a
complicated concept that's going on the
only thing that's nasty is the
repetitiveness of all of this
yeah but Stephen if we glide it with
with the same icons that we need for the
entities and it's fine yeah okay well if
you can see a way to do that that's fine
I'm not I'm not thinking that through
completely okay let's continue here um
to extend an entity cloths and perform
various operations can delete the
properties you created by the extend I
what's the answer to that
can you repeat the answer is the answer
is cannery strip can you if you've if
you all and you I mean it doesn't you
can identity value entity value is the
thing that you used to say I just want
these ones it doesn't look like that
gives you the values what you can't get
okay let's say you have got an entity
cause you puffed it up by adding various
extensions to it and then you want to
deflate it again and remove extensions
what for
I mean I don't know what's going on but
I mean it doesn't matter but it's not
gonna compute anything it's all lazy
computation yeah exactly so it's only
what you asked for any value that you I
mean maybe we should have something any
value that says except if you have
15,000 and if you dream one what what do
you mean you mean I see you mean that
that you want to give a data set or
something of all but three of them or
something well then just list them I
think that's I don't know not I mean I
just think that in the entity word the
projection what is called projection
mean that even there in the relational
word doesn't really make much sense
alright let's keep reading down these
comments and then we need to go back to
the other other functions we have to
cover okay if you had an entity to a
home-brewed entity class is there a way
to delete it
add an entity
suppose you could use filtered entity
class okay so you had an answer T to an
entity class can you delete the entity
you
I'm not sure we've thought about that
reasonable question okay hold on let's
take a look here so well assume this is
a more like mutation if you are speaking
about the same class and we have
alterations which is that right okay so
what we have is a way to we have a way
to take okay so what you're saying is
all we can do is just symbolically and
cross to something which is there we
don't get to write back anything into
the database for example its first thing
and the second thing I'm saying is that
except for entity combined entity class
which in some cases you can think of as
adding few things we don't have things
yet in our set of primitives that will
add anything to existing entity class in
terms of entities so you can add
properties but you can we don't yet have
primitives to add entities produce
anything similar I see I see I see so
extended entity class is a property
extended entity class not an entity
extended and fixed yes
okay okay hold on um servants to class
right so the been on the live stream is
talking some more about the random
sampling business my opinion is that
what we will do eventually is that ran
sample density class will eventually be
quotes random right now we're saying
it's based on the internal
representation which means it's stable
well it's somewhat stable across calls
but I think in the future we'll say um
the
um yeah the in future world will them
will make it have random seating and so
on well easy Steven because we still
need the primitive that currently stands
for sample then it's a closet just to
take a part of it with certain ordering
in some cases fine well then maybe we
have random sample I think we haven't um
right um
yeah so Seth is suggesting making an
analogy and documentation between an
extended entity class and having columns
to a table I agree that that is a useful
thing to so
um
you
I agree we could say extended entity
class
you
effectively adds a column to each tape
to
to a table
representing
with a specified name and with to the
table um adds a column to a table
representing to a database table
representing
class with the new column named new and
having values F of entity sub I
problem with this is that in the future
we might have fields which are
represented by more than one column in
the table
and so are in that case maybe we can
then change this in the future when we
start supporting these things no I think
it's useful it's useful comment because
it's it's somehow slightly de obfuscates
what's going on because they adds a
column to a database table representing
class and also I think this should be
upper in there yes yes yes
you
well actually let's put it under
practically adds a column to a database
table represent a class with a new
column name new and having values
um
having value F of entity I for
each entity entity I
you
okay next
[Music]
okay what happens to entity a bacterium
when the bacterium might totally you
know splits in two
yeah good question this is a whole
welcome to the world of entities and
objects and so on um
to close
you
yeah we know about restriction too close
okay piece of trivia for everybody I
once met EF Cod but there was some time
in the as an old chap at that time and
they in the early eighties and he had
written a book about cellular automata
and it was about that was I think what
he studied before he studied um before
he was at IBM studying relational
algebra and so on he had worked on
several tours up there just piece of
trivia um and needless to say when I met
mr. Cod
talked about primarily about cellular
automata and I had no idea he was
working on relational databases um
okay so Seth is is commenting on you
know by mistake you add a bunch of stuff
well but you know what your underlying
database is not modified by anything you
do here you can just go back to whatever
you know there's just a bunch of big
symbolic structure and I would say if
you want to get rid of extensions that
you've made just use that class inside
without I mean everything you have is
represented by the symbolic structure
you've built up you don't I think if you
want to unwind it just go back on that
symbolic structure don't it's not like
something happened in the background
that updated it does that make sense to
be you know what Steven I think
then our remark about the effectively
adds a column to a database table isn't
quite correct we should say okay okay
it's a column to a query to a virtual
table represented by query something
like that
effectively represents
virtual well a database table a virtual
database table um
derived from the derived from class with
the new column hadith yes with a new
column named new added with values F of
entity I for each entity of entity I
okay hold on that's some
you
okay wait a minute so you know somewhere
and all of this stuff we should say
every one of these functions should say
extended entity class works with
this has got to be boilerplate for a
bunch of these works with relational
database objects
with both relational database and entity
store objects
that correct that's a little bit I mean
entity stores are also built from
relational database objects so they are
all in the stores we want to say that it
works for different backends okay with
footwork works with any entity store but
but you don't have to explicitly have an
entity store around your relational
database there's no explicit mention of
entities store
I'm afraid you have to
because if you don't register that
energy story you can't even start your
workflow with the relationally that I
see okay works with any entity store
object whether defined explicitly or
based on an external
is that a useful statement
I think so okay then this is boilerplate
we need to add to essentially every one
of these entity class operating
functions and it probably has to be also
rather high in the list of things we
mentioned here okay not everything can
be at the top yeah I know but because
it's generic it should be I think it
should be upper then things related to
specifically relational database things
and cetera well okay so what do you want
to put it I think third maybe actually
no even second
alright ok let's keep going here
yeah been on the livestream is pointing
out that we keep on obsessing about
database connections that's because this
is the team that's worked on database
connections mostly but that these things
are also very useful for ordinary entity
store constructs which I agree with all
right can we um
okay so by the way so this would have in
it um
[Music]
that's just a sample of how this would
work okay let's keep going now um so
what we've got to do next
okay combined entity class oh boy oh boy
is this really complicated
which should I do first if we're gonna
run out of time which one should we have
done should we have done um
gated
and they're both pretty important okay
well let's see if I can wrap my brain
around any of them okay represents a
class of entities obtained by merging
the properties of pair of cement cities
maybe should say combining now that was
dealing with from urge to combine
especially since that's what I read by
combining the properties of pairs of
entities from class one and class two by
combining the properties
you
of those pairs of entities from class
one and class two for which that right
yep yes those pairs of entities from
class minecraft for which prop
as the same value I guess yeah as the
same value for which the value of prop
is the same for which
you
you
you
you
you know any function whose description
is that complicated it's hard to
understand
um the class of entities
yeah but it's one of the most
non-trivial operations in this algebra
you
okay represents a class of entities
which all the values of the properties
prop I
well
containing only and it is for only those
entities
wait a minute when it pairs of entities
is it the same entity
you think one from class one and one
come from class 2 they can you compare
old pairs no I understand up but then
this is saying represents the class of
entities containing only I think the
start of this should be the same as in
the first place in the first definition
because we still can look at pairs of
entities and the only thing that is
different is that we're comparison not
comparing not one property but several
of them yeah
represents the close whence is obtained
in properties
you
well okay wait a minute
look why don't we just say combines
those combines pairs of entities where
all which
the values of all the properties prop I
are the same
that reasonable the same for both
entities in the pair again
that's it's just simple forum it's just
I don't think okay so here
okay so this is
you
doesn't this case when it this case
you
really should be something like L and R
because it's going to because you can
also have this can't you you can have a
list of of pairs of properties
I don't like this this is how would we
number this wait a minute this is
confusing see what I'm saying
[Music]
still in the second usage line should it
say corresponding property values are
the same because not all have to be the
same
as president it is for that means for
the corresponding values
you want to add the word corresponding
there someday yes
I don't know whether that really helps
okay the thing I'm worrying about is the
indexing of 1/2 here because we've got
class 1 class 2
but yet these prop ones aren't the same
as the one twos here
I don't think I've ever done it this way
but I think we could to say prop a prop
B and so on here
we have to do that I don't see I think
otherwise it's super confusing
I think that's what we have to do okay
so this this
okay here we're saying
okay we have some comments on the
livestream I'm gonna look at for a
second um right now we can write entity
a probably one property - and create a
new entity in an entity so you're saying
you can use entity of property property
equals value one by value equals value
in an entity store how do you get rid of
that property if you made a mistake in
an in-memory entity store can't you just
use equals dot
Tony
yes unsaid should be supported
documented somewhere
I guess not documented
and maybe even needs to be on a guide
page if we have it does there a guide
page it talks about L values for fans at
his store
but still and I think we should be
pretty careful with mutations because if
later on for some reason we decide to
support some kind of schemas also for
in-memory entity stores know that
bridges already crossed we could you can
already do L value stuff in Tony's
entity store framework correct Tony yes
but is it document that like for example
removing a property from a single entity
in all cases well the only thing that's
documented is entity of property equals
value so it's not your document that's -
hmm I mean well I kind of agree with you
that it would be nice to be able to add
a schema layer map and if we do that we
should think carefully about mutations
because otherwise we will create
backwards incompatibilities well are you
confident that the entity of property
equals value is okay oh yes well I mean
it can't be because if entity of
property is equal to value then at least
you are not removing a property on a
base on a single entity basis you are
maybe you can have type mismatch but you
can't have things like of the same class
some some properties have some sorry
somebody's have some properties and
others don't which will be completely
breaking the schema if it exists
um yeah hey listen I've got a logistical
thing here can somebody can we push this
polyhedron thing at least 15 minutes
later somebody do that there is another
thing that it's kind of worrying me
about entity store it's the fact that I
mean we deprecated dollar entity stores
but no there isn't any stores open close
and they can't get out of sync and I
think that's wrong what can get out of
sync okay so if you say you do dollar
entity stores equal a list with an
artist or net
but we didn't have tolerance these
stores it's gone we have it still it
still works I don't care I don't care
it's not documented it as far as I'm
concerned it's an internal feature I
don't care about it
you
so let's just go through some of these
other things on the live stream let's
come back to this okay um
a resolver and should not be mixed up
with a primitive projection entity class
which is the algebraic and inverse of
extended entity class I we obviously
need to think about projection energy
cost let's put that on the shelf for
right now um
okay entity list of entity class
something comma all has changed whenever
you add any registered entities store
object to sucess
do we need to worry about
okay wait a minute
um
yeah call is pointing out the this
statement the statement is generic and
search should be high up in the
documentation is this is is not a
sensible thing like it requires internet
access is down at the bottom usually but
yes I think it's slightly different okay
Drago is saying we should reconsider the
documented feature the extended entity
classes can have two properties with the
same name
but the full name of the property is not
the string and is just a convenience
that the string works so the issue is
whether we should go out on a limb and
document the fact that the things can
clash or whether we should merely I
think we do need to do that I think we
need to do that I'm okay with that
um Seth is commenting that you're
letting users add two entities store um
so it
Seth is merely is is basically saying we
should document unset of entity of
property even if we don't have any of
these multi setting things and so on
and I kind of agree with that by the
time we have entered their property
equals value be documented we better
have entity of property equals dot be
documented as well but still if you
remember my argument from five minutes
ago if that unsetting is not yet
documented I think we should at least
think about this in conjunction with the
bigger picture where we might consider
also a schema of why is unsetting
haven't we already crossed the bridge of
employment in something by the time we
have setting wise unsetting any
different because if you are removing
entity or a sorry entity property
altogether from an entity it's different
from just unsetting its value to some
default value so if unsetting means that
you are simply setting a value to some
default then it's fine if unsetting
means that you are totally removing
property from Isis then you're changing
the schema yes and not in a way that is
compatible with the schema because in
the schema you can only change you know
table wide why it's not no I understand
I understand sir what do you do the
question is what do you set it to do you
set it to missing not set or something
if you say equals dot are you basically
I would be fine with missing but not was
a removal of a property okay so the
question is would it be consistent which
I don't think it is to have equals dot
set something to missing that's very
weird I mean that's not what equals dot
usually does
hmm anybody else want to comment on this
well if you think Association and then
you do evil dot and then you try to
extract that thing then you get a
missing I think that's the I see what
you're saying right in spirit
yeah I kind of agree with you I kind of
agree that makes sense all right that
makes sense now but but the question is
of what's stored I mean in terms of what
the user sees what will come out is
missing not set
and whether that is what is explicitly
stored in the database or not is up to
us
okay but now okay so Seth is now saying
but what if he wants to remove an entity
we will have that functionality I'm
pretty sure just not for this release
that will require not a primitive that
we currently don't have in this algebra
of things we defined how do you add an
entity how do you add an entity in this
whole world move we've got indirectly
well but how entity of property cost
value and if the entity doesn't exist
yet it is introduced
okay but but but here's a question
you've got a thing called we've got a
thing called extended entity class right
that is in fact extending the entity
class by virtue of adding properties we
could extend an entity class by virtue
of adding entities what does that we
don't have it yet but one way of doing
that would be to have our operation
similar to SQL Union Hall or Union where
you would just combine entities that you
want to add into a entity class and then
you join two entity classes but join in
this sense okay so I'm I'm concerned
about the following thing the name
extended entity class what do we think
the name will be for an entity class
which has had entities added to it it
would be I think it would be something
like Union dancing class or joined
entity class because it will still
operate an entity class is not in single
entities it's not going to be like
append it's going to I understand that
I'm just worried about the term extended
being how are you extending it I mean
it's a property extended entity classes
whether you get that problems with
combined if you think about it why
because you are come
infectivity on the properties but you
could be combined on the entities as
well it's it's that's why the word join
in SQL is confusing people will come
from or from language and that's why we
called it join across because it's like
one is horizontal one is vertical yes
okay why do I think this is not gonna be
the last meeting in this series oh by
the way still you have this the third
the third line definition contains
something which is underlined the red so
there is no well because I was typing in
that word well we got distracted okay
okay okay all right let's go back to
this and try and wrap this for a second
here okay so
okay so here combines pairs of entities
compilers it's a nice word actually
as something cross between
nevermind conspire and okay combines
pairs of entities
for which the pairs of entities from
class 1 and class 2 for which the value
of prop 1
of the entity from class one is the same
as the value of prop 2 for the entity
from class 2 is that right yep okay
I think that could be the second usage
line okay
and then we generalize to a list for
both cases right
you
you
you
you
okay combines percentages which for
you
the property specifications
you
for which all the property
specifications
P spec k agree
come but note for
five forgotten again who's who's peeing
this for Andrea sorry
something this um note for you we need
to figure out how to perform at his ease
and B subscripts correctly okay because
that's not the standard doc you tools
thing okay
oh boy
well shouldn't this be the third entity
third thing that's somewhat different F
in that case is a general condition that
allows you to do anything list anything
oh I see I see I see I see represents
okay
okay combines pairs of entities for
which the application of the entity
function f yields true
right yes
mrs. chase back to determined
when to allow entities containing
missing elements or could I get it
what the heck is this
you
supported by the last two arguments what
does that mean
deviations and third in force but what
does it even mean I mean the always but
I go more in detail later you can delete
it
it's not very important okay I mean what
I'm slightly worried about is that there
is one one of the usage messages
the third namely now which prob might be
easy sorry the third detail might need
the users message
the third detail of what of combine NT
class cannot have two identical first
argument
sorry I said it again the combined
entity class cannot have two identical
first arguments
you
oh my gosh oh my gosh why is this
well how do you distinguish them then
properties will have will be ambiguous
you know this is the case where you like
jogging one person with their father and
so they both have prizes you have to
name the the property
what is that syntax for entity property
there is that a new wacky syntax for
entity property I mean now entity
poverty can have a complex forced
argument as we've seen with the extended
entity class well there's some
algebra of those are aliased properties
and types that we might have to review
is this the first time I've seen one
we have probably Sean oh no no it's not
the first time you see it so the general
rule is this when when when an entity
class like construct adds properties so
the first entity class like construct
where that thing gets put in the first
argument you know what bothers me about
this whole thing is you know relational
algebra is a fairly clean set of
concepts at some level I guess
the problem is that nobody in the wild
world really ever implemented relational
algebra because it works with sets and
you want to be sorting you know there is
all sorts of the old things that make
any kind of implementation scale deviate
from relational algebra but that's not
only that it's also that entity model
doesn't really 100% fall in relational
algebra and for example when relational
algebra doesn't state what you do with
the properties was duplicated names it
just states that you can rename them but
then it's up to you how you do that yeah
it's it's the underbelly of practically
every formal computer science II type
thing from you know nested lambdas to
other things this business about and
then you have to you know and the names
have to be yeah the renaming thing is a
nasty underbelly of a lot of things and
there's actually still while we're at it
I have to say that I think we've come up
with a very very nice and very well
thought-out scheme to rename things
which is clean and just has a few
orthogonal concepts so well in this
particular case I mean the fact is that
renaming in general like with nested
lambdas and so on is you know that's a
total mess yeah but for this particular
case we I wonder whether we can learn
something for that case from from I mean
because you know the case that is a
total mess right now is I mean and by
the way this is not our mess this is
this is a mess that's been around for at
least 100 years
you
you
and I think we get credit for syntax
coloring that mess but there's the mess
now is there a way to use what we are
doing now for these probably probably
not I don't think so because here the
problem arises from us using a single
flat namespace and another languages
this problem is solved by using nested
namespaces oh this isn't solved the
nested lambdas thing I mean we have
plenty of names places too and if we
change the namespace we'd obviously get
the right you know we'd be able to do
this no no it's still 1 we still have a
flat namespace
we have nested names for them but they
are all in the single flat symbol table
we don't have nested symbol tables so to
speak yeah but that wouldn't I mean but
whatever I don't think that helps you
that would help here so how well but the
price the price for that would be that
function will no longer be transparent
for pattern matching or things like that
it will become a black box you know so
there is a price to pay for that
and so maybe for Wolfram language it's
just the wrong thing to do because the
price is too high one function to remain
transparent about and mashing and things
other things right but the fact is what
you're doing here because this is all
lazy through I think the reason this
works you know there's several reasons
this works I mean so you're forcing a
name here I mean this alias forcing a
name I mean clearly what I could do here
is I could say you know foo backtick
this and then I have no problem
right yeah we certainly are don't have
the level of automation in this
construct for entity classes that
automatic scoping gives us in other
cases but in the sense we we don't
consider this as a really a scoping I
mean an a fully automatic scoping
construct in a way all right yes we are
kind of asking them to participate in
creating this unique namespaces let's
look at aggregated entity class for a
second before we go into these these
notes here um on the on the hope that
it'll be the same set of issues
represent sensory class containing
what
okay I don't understand this at all
containing a single entity with a single
entity property
what is this
so this is like forgetting the total of
an end of some
um can somebody explain this
somebody - yeah so basically look at the
first example Stephen okay
you
how does it deal with missings I mean
obviously there's this is I mean it
really should have a cleaner way of
dealing with missings than to have to
say I don't even know where the delete
missing works on this
probably not but I mean in SQL there is
a there is a clear syntax but like clear
semantics of how machines are treated so
in SQL that missing will be treated as
zero well why because total has some
kind of I mean you know it's some what
is the identity element the LD there
because the identity element of sound a
zero no I understand that but how does
it know that I mean in other words then
you have to define for a given entity
function well the point is that the
aggregator is the trustee for things of
an empty set much yeah a total of an
empty set returns missing but total of
two and missing these two that's that
one I'm sure okay so how do we do this
because this is gonna come up all the
time that there's going to be missing
data in the aggregator and it's it's a
mess I mean for for SQL it's not a big
problem because basically there are five
widely used and find you know backhands
aggregators and they are like total mean
standard deviation count mean a max
that's it so-called missing function
right what was it called curry has an
option called missing behavior
okay
what is this how does this relate to the
stuff of machine learning functions I
thought we had something called missing
there is one in temporal data that's
clue missing
we seen data method oh great
you
um
I think we have a little bit of a mess
on our hands I think missing behavior
and missing data method are similar what
is missing data rules Oh No
oh gosh
all right listen this is going to
require another discussion
you
this is gonna require what's what's
gonna be needed in the end it's missing
value pattern is going to need to be
supported with default underscore
missing probably
then some combined version of missing
data rules missing data method and
missing behavior needs to be brought
into these functions
and I don't think this is right either
missing string should surely be combined
with like missing behavior
okay we we should have in the hahaha we
should have a missing meeting so to
speak to talk about these and
could you to find that and get it get it
and we'll need a different set of an
additional set of people who have been
involved in these various functions here
so the machine learning folk well Oscar
TM but Polly Etienne himself and also
that missing string thing I think that's
sure ohms and I don't even know what
missing style is that's yet another oh
my golly gosh this is embarrassing
there's been look at this this is this
is I mean and I'm sure I've been
involved in every one of these so this
is just embarrassing because what we've
got here is
yeah I mean missing star missing
behavior missing data method they're all
related coastally related
humph they're all a little different but
they should be combined or at least have
a well understood correspondence so in
this case well we're not gonna get it
for this version obviously but I think
in the future we should expect to have
some missing behavior type option
now Seth is pointing out and I think
correctly that entity function could
have that
start right
is that right is it entity function that
would have that um because there is a
certain lady for body options even it
might help you and William what default
value was an option we interviews for
templating template slots okay can you
make sure Andrea that's something else
for the missing meeting
okay so we will have two meetings one to
finish documentation that we are just
having just very few things left and the
other one about with the other team's
about missing things that is correct
okay and the first of those is a you
know has to be done for version 12 to be
wrapped up the second one is not going
to make it for 12 oh okay yeah but we
are almost done with documentation they
updated didn't they all functions
they're all symbols you already passed
through them but I think Carlo and Tony
made updates okay but but hold on I just
want to understand where does the
missing treatment go because it's
already too late isn't it by the time
entity function
what is being given as the argument what
is e here
but Izzy in that case it's the whole
class not one entity the resolution of
the missingness only happens when that
class is is shattered into a list that's
the time when it knows that had
something missing it's not the whole of
see what I'm saying so it's deep inside
the entity function that the missingness
shows up
yeah
and I don't think we can say any missing
that shows up just set it to zero
because we could say total and then we
could have something which is a product
or something and we want to sell to one
I mean it depends on what function it's
in yeah so one thing we could do is to
set default behavior for which for each
of the aggregate functions we're
supporting but yeah self is pointing out
that the other it needs to be an
aggregated entity class that the that
the missingness because it's that
property there
that we need to say if it's missing
yeah it's two levels of stuff here right
so that property is being aggregated
with that function f
if I'm not mistaken but that's a result
not the property that is being
aggregated
in property and it can involve company
understanding but I'm saying if if that
this F here represents Santa Claus
you
you
you
what is the name of that entity
that soul entity that's there
can be anything will give me candy but
it is something definite right it must
generate something for that name
just an either empty list of one I don't
remember what we decided at the end
blah blah one Carl do remember but by
saying listen how does this return how
is this even an entity cost at the end
of it
oh I see because you're giving you're
asking for the value so if I were to do
this without that value resolver they're
here trying to trace all this yeah it's
an end to this that what is that list of
properties so this is consistent
why is that consistent look at that
take the example below yes a constant
good coochie gamma this one here this
one Yad when Z list on that one this one
here yeah
oh gosh
oh what a mess
Oh all right we have to have another
meeting and yes I agree the the
discussion about missing data is a more
general problem
okay um hmm I I don't like this whatever
this is this is a hack whatever you're
doing here it's a hack the fact that
it's a nothing there and then it's one
two three four here come on guys I mean
it's one two three because those are the
periods what yeah I mean if you are
going it by continent you get continents
there in this case periods are cool one
two three four five six seven it's not a
generated thing still miss Kay okay okay
okay fine but in this case it is
generated I mean it's the it's the
limiting version if you if you do a
residency in the last argument of that
period you put period and group yeah
then you'll get both of them okay okay
okay okay okay all right okay
I retract it does seem reasonable okay
but but so then this so you're starting
the documentation with this corner case
what's the difference between this case
here
I am really confused this is the
shorthand you proposed so that you can
just write population goes to total and
set out the event right and see function
yes I understand we better have this how
on earth are we gonna document that um I
think we're gonna have to say
um okay let me try one try for this an
NC class containing a single entity
[Music]
you
you
with the property prop whose value is
the result of applying function f2
class basically now we have to define
what that function f is later there are
two forms for that function
f
okay so here we just say F 1 of 2
etcetera etcetera
you
um
then we remove this and we say in this
thing here
you
the function f kin must be can either be
an entity function object
or can be a function fun
that will be
treated
you
you
that will be
you
you
you
something like that I think but so this
means that the prop in this case is at
the same time the property over which we
aggregate and the property and the name
of the resulting aggregated property in
the result right
stupid isn't it yeah but I don't see how
in this syntax you can separate the two
because you basically need two not one
in general
you
well it's not completely stupid if this
was a mean for example it would be okay
I mean it's okay so then it's the same
named property or does that tangle up
somewhere else no probably not
but it says nothing about the action
that was performed to aggregate and it
basically says just what the property
was used no it says the action is fun
which could be mean for example yeah I'm
saying the name of the resulting
property doesn't say anything involved
exactly yes it but but that's okay if
look in other words if you want to say
okay population for example you want to
say total that the the population of the
entity class is going to be the total of
the populations of the answer days in it
and you don't really need to say total
population population isn't up the
population of Europe is the sum of the
populations of its countries yeah well
the thing if you are doing the average
it will still say population that's
correct so don't do average in that case
because that this is this is the
shorthand case which we've used many
many many times where you're basically
saying you know like the average you
know the temperature in January is
you'll you'll want the average you know
if you just asked for the temperature in
January you're gonna get the average
temperature in January I think it's
right I think this is okay
all right let's try to get this next
meeting soon um I am Tripp on Wednesday
so let's try to get it before then
please okay um let me just see the
livestream here
maybe users have to
how to handle missings in aggregated
entity class yeah but better bagger in
the future I agree
um think of basic area Jan Kaas creating
a table with a single row and as many
columns as you have aggregation
functions I agree
when you add groupings
a table with as many rows as groups yes
yes right as many columns as aggregation
functions
know that as many columns aggregation
function is not correct it will have
this many columns at least Popeye okay
so if you have both prop and grouping
the number of properties is the sum of
prop removing some of the lengths
sizzles no that doesn't make sense to me
because this this grouping is giving
entities
basically the properties that form the
aggregated properties in the second case
they form the primary key of the new
entities and they are separate from the
properties obtained through aggregations
listen unfortunately I have to go deal
with something else here um a minor
polyhedron emergence say hard to believe
that there are such things um okay um
okay so we will continue let me push
these changes back
thanks very much to everybody including
folks on the livestream who made all
kinds of useful suggestions much
appreciated all right see you guys soon